bene i ragazzi per dio questo nuovo
video sarà un po di genere oggi facciamo
una roba un po diversa perché era un po
che non facevo un unboxing ma ci hai
messo sono di zelda bravissimo giampiero
bravi rinvii del pensiero da nvidia mi
ha inviato a 2.080 su perché è la
alleviata al nostro amico frigeni perché
agli iscritti vi faccio vedere che cosa
ho imparato in cinque anni di
informatica perché monteremo una scheda
video infatti oggi per montare la scheda
grafica c'è il mio amico ale vieni
allertarsi elia copiano i compiti da lui
oggi mi monta ovviamente nella scheda
adesso andiamo a sfilare gentilmente la
scatola tale nanna ditzel rimesso
bravissimo ragazzi questo è il look
esterno della 2080 super molto
riflettuto molto bella se guardate bene
nel riflesso si vede il mio treppiedi da
povero andiamo a inserire la nostra
scheda grafica nel computer ma
finalmente entriamo dove son capace di
metter le mani
ok ora arrivo io m de ma grazie quindi
ragazzi ho montato finalmente la mia
nuovissima scheda grafica tutto da solo
merito mio e possiamo iniziare quindi a
testarla per testarla ragazzi giocherò
call of duty modern warfare l'unica roba
che vi dico è che siccome sto giocando
alla beta che tra l'altro è uscita da un
minuto e mezzo quindi ci saranno tutti
pro players non mi sto giustificando se
fanno schifo ti volevo dire appunto che
essendo una beta la tecnologia rtx non
funziona però quando uscirà il gioco
ufficiale ci sarà anche la tecnologia
rtx cos'è la tecnologia lte della scheda
grafica directx sarebbe raytracing che
quella tecnologia che ti permette di
bussare in modo incredibile di qualità
intendo le luci le ombre e riflessi nei
giochi in modo tale che si veda
praticamente realistico in modo
incredibile peccato che preso la vetta
non funzioni però sul gioco finale
funzioni ha dato anche in minecraft c'è
questa cosa quindi incredibile il late
ragazzi invidia anche introdotto nelle
schede rtx la tecnologia ai framework
gaming bam miac inglese grazie alla
tecnologia nvidia sulle nuove schede rtx
possiamo raggiungere livelli
incredibili di fps in tutti quanti
giochi in descrizione trovate i link per
maggiori informazioni più il bundle che
hanno fatto tra rtx e cod
andiamo a giocare a cod siamo su non
solo e siamo però vabbè utilizziamo loud
che è una delle mie armi preferite tra
l'altro di modern warfare degli altri ma
per qua e un po ballerino però molto che
le ha il dominio
che figata dove non avevo ancora fatta
allora c'è uno li scappato eccolo ora
sono miglior migliore al mondo a posto
eh no ragazzi ve lo giuro poco demonio
che jump square
avevo registrato due partite fighissime
avevo chiuso con un rateo di due quasi
una roba allucinante niente non mi ha
preso le riprese non mi ha preso la
ripresa non si può dire in un commento
ri proveniente da ho visto no
madonna sono saltato sulla claim quanto
stiamo al tanto io dovrei giocare anche
per conquistare le bandiere
effettivamente quindi muoviamoci
l'uomo ha tolto la terza che il cielo
love ragazzi cecchino poi dovrei avere
la mappa grossa quindi è bellissimo
usare il cecchino qua dopo voglio
sbucciare nonostante la partita mi
stiano bene
è un suicidio switch aree qui tre di
fila c'è già il web quindi non lo devi
lancio sono sempre perfetto quattro di
fila o buono è incredibile la sto
riprendendo una partita che strano prova
a prenderli un pelo da dietro eccoli lì
ma non ha preso qui da dietro
avevo il missile come si chiama il
missile cruise si chiama non è più il
predator ragazzi come modern warfare 2
crisi come tom cruise
ecco il cecchino dai switch amo chi se
ne frega se beni che adesso faccio
schifo madonna che dovevo ricaricare
guarda ma perché perché il cecchino
scarico madonna guarda lo sapevo io lo
sapevo
ho ragazzi siamo passati da fare una
partita incredibile go il cecchino che
non va preso maledizione a questo
amerini che ci sono gli altri
comportamenti personalizzati adesso
metto il cecchino raga perché non so se
ci faccia una bella figura però mi
diverte quindi chi se ne frega paola
aspri akil per gli altri e non per me ma
che orco il demonio ogni volta che mira
da una parte c'è uno che mi sta puntando
dall'altra e sta cosa io la detesto tra
l'altro ragazzi ho bruciato tutti i
settaggi al massimo per sfruttare al
massimo nel 2080 s
c'è tanta gente ma cosa ma da dove no
dai non è vero la pistola fa schifo o no
mi sono dovuto concentrare perché
occorre di mancarlo ragazzi ci provo
perché me lo sento
ecco buono buono buono
no madonna dove ricaricare e chi meno
buonissimo ma quattro no porca vacca
nessun ok una porta sola chiudere tutte
e due che te ne frega di una
chiudilettera be o l'utilità di chiudere
una porta
ecco non è vero ma è molto denso e morto
mi sia cruise
qua c'è la grana tina speriamo che mi
serve allora missile cruise ragazzi
questo tipo il predator si sgancia e tu
puoi andarci 1 con la claymore nel
mentre questo non opere successive sette
chili fila buono c'è chi non è male dove
la beta mancato buono tutti di fila
bellissimo
no il nemico dolci credo non mi ha
sparato come mai il pensavo anche anche
lui pensa così un compagno 9 di fila
buonissimo 10 di figli lapo l'inizio
action porca vacca e un compagno costi
jump square 10 di fila buono ragazzina
partita dai cioè per essere la prima di
rec porco demonio buono proprio lui che
chiama l'elicottero madonna ragazzi che
sarà buona e allo comandi tu da vero che
fino ragazzi credibile mandola l'ala
nucleare 12 13 ma non ci credo
13 e non vedo la gente 14 dai non è
morto 15 16
la maledizione 18 19
no non ho preso no 19 definita 19 di
fila davvero ma che figata
ma sono molto no che tratto non ho
capito però è bello bellissimo allora
ragazzo li voglio vedere se riesco
utilizzare la m4 non so se c'è alle mie
quattro i primi a bella stamattina una
donna e casino che fanno sti cosi con le
cuffie non ve lo so dire ragazzi implosa
la casa però c'è gente ovunque
non riesco a capire stanno a cuore
veramente un che fa le miss poi cambiare
arma perché tar corte di mtv il cecchino
no perché mamma mia uno va bene 2 dove
due sono io o due per lo spoiler cattura
quindi teoricamente i nomi quali
teoricamente ma non praticamente non li
vedo tecnico ma porco i demoni o quello
incastrato nelle i pertugi l'attenzione
a c ci sono io su cima al cecchino
ragazzi non ce la posso far apprendere
la parte che ho sbagliato strada
ma dove si passa per andare suu kyi
ragazzi non solo un cecchino sarei un
pazzo a metà ci provo ragazzi io sono un
cecchino sono un pazzo ha tentato di
conquistare miss b avvisa che paura ogni
volta incredibile ma spuntano alcune in
3 2 1
e invece no e basta
2 non c'è nessuno daino km non c'è
nessuno
c'è un elicottero con la chiamata ok
penso di essere l'unico ci metto può
ammirare ragazzi ho notato sta cosa
prova di ricaricare l'arma che sono
sempre in un ragazzino sono tutti dentro
la caverna ragazzo lo dico io si può
salire ma sopra ma dai
bellissimo no davi interrotto la scala
ma per favore ma è distrutto un sogno
sono tutti dentro la caverna sicuro però
anche la caverna d'aragon cecchino sarei
un pazzo ma come ho fatto a non prendere
come come non l'ha come non l'ha preso
ma come non l'ha preso mai comunque
bello sto frigo ben piazzato
complimenti mi piace il frigo certa
mappa bravo prossima volta non parlo del
frigo perché sono le magistra però va
bene ma tra jolie paro mobile vuol dire
che tu lo piazza in giro ti può riparare
sotto e cecchinare musica non serve a
niente ma perché prova
ma va giù dopo un po ma che schifo fatto
o maiga e sarebbe stato incredibile però
la mancata preso dopo dai c'è sempre con
la dentro lo mancato no non vedo nulla
bravo lacerante giusta sconfitta come ma
porca vacca è finita praticamente
cecchinato gioco accordo veramente da
sei anni però mi ricordo i tempi su un
mondo warfare 2 e sul primo ma delle
volte ma sul 2 ma è così incredibile ero
veramente infognato come un topo però
veramente figo bellissimo ringrazio
invidia per aver sponsorizzato questo
video e per avermi hanno dato la 2080 s
fatemi sapere se il video vi è piaciuto
come al solito ragazzi mi è piaciuta
sotto un commento vi piace iscrivetevi
al canale schiacciatela campanellina
bellissima che trovate vicino a tassi
iscriviti e noi come sempre ci vediamo
ad un prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]